Huntington disease is a degenerative
disease of the central nervous system
it's an inherited disease caused by a
mutation in the huntington gene symptoms
of Huntington disease typically develop
in adulthood and include changes in
movement cognition and behavior there is
no cure current treatments only reduce
the symptoms the normal function of the
Huntington gene is not fully understood
but it is important for the development
of the nervous system the mutation
itself is quite distinctive there are
too many repeats of a sequence in the
gene where the basis bel CAG this
trinucleotide codes for the amino acid
glutamine more than 40 repeats lead to a
mutated protein with an unusually long
chain of glutamine such a long protein
invariably causes disease mutated
Huntington proteins are broken down to
shorter fragments by caspases cal pains
and other proteases but how these
fragments cause toxicity is not wholly
clear the most studied fragment called h
TTX on one can take different
confirmations and combine to various
other proteins so it's a challenge to
find out how this fragment contributes
to disease development however h TTX on
one can form aggregates including
tangles of amyloid fibrils similar
aggregates are also present in other
neurodegenerative diseases including
outs Hyman disease Parkinson disease and
mi atrophic lateral sclerosis or ALS in
Huntington disease - these aggregates
might be responsible for the toxic
effects of mutated Huntington
you